hey everyone dear volley here and in today's video
we are jumping back into the dopast world that is
gegeokutamis jujutsu kaizen and going over the
entire izodory extermination arc that directly
follows after the aftermath of the world altering
shibuya incident arc obviously so freaking much
happened throughout the last arc that has
completely altered the landscape of the story
like gojo getting sealed a huge number of
sorcerers and civilians dying including the
nine to five working goat nanami shibuya district
itself getting completely and utterly destroyed
all of the cursed spirits that have teamed up with
pseudo ghetto getting either killed or assimilated
freaking toji for shiguru got re-summoned at
literally the height of his strength sukuna's
utter domination and destruction and of course the
big and final reveal that was braincon activating
a countrywide idol transfiguration therefore
sending the world of jujutsu back into the
golden age of jujutsu techniques obviously there
is so much more that i just have not included so
if you want to refresh yourself before literally
continuing the aftermath of shibuya because that's
what this arc is the hype still somehow continues
it's literally insanity then go back and check out
that video that i made like two or three weeks
ago now and also a few are new around here and
wants more content just like this where i go
over entire stories arcs fights and pretty
much anything from manga or anime and way too
much detail then make sure you hit the subscribe
button and also be sure to leave a like on the
video as it really helps out with the algorithm
anyway enough of that let's finally get into this
arc so as we start back out we see tokyo at night
slowly as it zooms out it reveals that the entire
area is now pitch black okay like giga straight of
a bat comes out and hits us with the hanza hunter
level of info dumb literally like the text covers
the whole page and another complete double panel
afterwards anyways anyways random people begin
discussing this situation and reveal that the
23 wards have almost been completely destroyed
by the way these wards are like just like
districts or areas of tokyo that it's broken
up into because it's such a large place anyways
anyways these randoms who'll probably introduce
you to higher-ups or japanese officials plan to
create an evacuation plan for 5 million residents
estimating that at least 10 million cursed spirits
have been released one of them is flabbergasted
that they plan to evacuate the entire area
wondering about what the various consequences
could be another say is that they should expand
the two barriers to the boundaries of the
prefecture and another worries about making public
the existence of cursed spirits which you know
obviously confirms that it's probably jiu-jitsu
higher-ups talking about this stuff right here
someone assures the others that these sorcerers
are protecting the evacuees inside the city
with another adding that they can tell the public
that the cursed spirits only appear in tokyo
as someone else worries about an intervention by
foreign military the others debate back and forth
about how to handle the situation with nothing
ever being cemented elsewhere at the same time
in a convenience store a young girl kneels on the
floor when she suddenly spots a creepy figure in
the doorway telling her to come just really weird
when you put it like that the confused girl asks
where her mother is and the figure replies that
everyone is all outside safe with him she says in
response that she doesn't have a brother but the
figure simply repeats the girl's words which just
leaves her even more confused the figure stays to
come again and as the girl walks outside a horrid
cursed spirit with razor sharp teeth opens its
mouth to devour her finally like i've been waiting
so long to talk about this dude since i dropped
my jk0 video people have been asking where and
like how what happened to him you know like
well here he is leaping down from above the
one and only yuta akotsu suddenly appears
and stabs the creature directly in its head
with a calming smile on his face he asks the girl
if she's scared while also making sure that she
isn't hurt yuda notes the area and doubts that she
lives here then noticing how worn her shoes are he
asks how far she's walked as yuda tells her that
she has done a good job the curse suddenly rises
up from the ground and opens its mouth to devour
him but it's suddenly thrown back and splattered
against the wall as the girl notices the attack
luther asks reeker to chill out a little while
also covering the girl's eyes and turning her away
from the carnage by the way like i should mention
i'm like 80 sure that this is during the morning
on the 1st of november and maybe a day later but
i'm assuming that it's directly after the shibuya
incident arc because that's kind of like how i've
read it here anyway anyway moving forward in the
night yoona meets with these so called higher ups
who praise his efforts however he bluntly tells
them to get to the point one of them chuckles and
says that is killing of cursed spirits proves
nothing yudah asks in reply if he should enter
a binding vow assuring them that he will follow
through with any said plan he says that since yuji
itadori cut off inumahi's arm during shibuya then
he will kill him personally as the meeting ends
five notices are made known by the higher ups
first ghetto is confirmed to be alive and has
been sentenced to death again which is you know
like kind of funny but like obviously it's not
ghetto and surely they know that at this point or
like are trying not to believe it at this point
secondly gojo is considered an accomplice in
the incident and has been permanently exiled
removing his sale would be considered a criminal
act this is obviously you know something they
want they don't want uh someone who can threaten
their power to come back and actually kill them
like kojo has threatened them and they passed
before third masamichi yaga is to be freaking
executed for inciting gojo and ghetto and causing
the incident at shibuya pretty much their thought
behind this is that he's their teacher he gets
killed because you know like he should have
taught them better pretty much or at least you
know like there is another reason but we'll get
to that later on and not in this arc so we will
wait for that fourth yuji's execution will resume
now and be carried out immediately and lastly yuta
akotsu is appointed as yuji's executioner so we've
got a bit of a main story character rivalry going
on here right now the prequel or main story you
know who's your guy's favorite character out of
gigas two main characters anyway anyway skipping
forward to the zenith estates after being critical
of maki the misogynistic jjk andrew tate this
small man himself naoya joins ogie and junichi
as they wait for the news about naobito's death
naoh criticizes his two relatives which causes
them to get aggravated after naoya like these
sly mofo he is defuses the entire situation that
he created which is like more than andrew tate
could ever achieve a man named for a darcy i hope
i got there right i probably didn't enters and
informs the three that the old man now be too has
passed away due to his injuries he reads now beat
his will and announces that naoh will become the
27th head of the xenon family and inherit all of
his assets once he is approved by either oogie
or junichi however in an utterly bizarre twist
of fate for adate then reveals that there is a
clause based on a written agreement with toji
it states that if gojo has died or become mentally
incapacitated mikami fushiguru will assume the
role of head instead hearing this naoya is left
furious and knows that the others would prefer
to have anyone other than himself as the head of
the clan he quickly learns from a female attendant
that megami is looking for yuji in tokyo and
tells her to inform the higher-ups that he will
kill yuji personally in addition he plans to take
advantage of the chaos in tokyo and kill megami to
cement his role as the head of the family skipping
away from probably my least favorite of the big
three families apart from you know maki and mai
of course but you know those two babes come soon
probably in the next arc i'm pretty sure
anyway flashing back we find yuki on the
phone with someone who she apologizes to for not
making a move sooner she clearly remarks that she
may not necessarily be on their side adding that
she just wants to rid the world of cursed spirits
she says that she and her comrades will
take responsibility for delivering the kids
who were present finally revealing that she plans
to confront tengen herself i'm guessing that she's
probably on the phone to a bunch of higher
ups like the same people that called her in
and you know if you guys have any dope theories
let me know down below be super interesting if she
was actually talking or like in coats with say
a roommate or another of these like mysterious
characters because that's just how she feels to
me right now she's a little bit mysterious and
still quite unknown like even even now in the
story so finally we make our way over to yuji as
he sits alone and despondent on a large staircase
josue approaches him and asks about his injuries
but yuji says that he is fine because it's kona
but can also tell that he is growing stronger
inside of him chosen says that he will be fined
by himself while he collects the remains of his
other family members and tells yuji that he can
return to jiu jitsu high however yuji replies
that sakuna has something planned for megami and
that he himself has killed too many people which
again reminds choso of his murdered brothers
calmly he says that it was a misunderstanding
and that forgiveness isn't involved when it comes
to brothers then as the two head out to deal with
more cursed spirits both naoya and yuta are
seen moving out to track yuji down and kill him
standing alone on a bridge yuji claps his hands
together multiple times to draw out several cursed
spirits he leads them down into an underpass where
chosu appears killing most of them with a single
shot from his piercing blood the one romani cursed
bird leaps towards cho so but yuji easily crushes
it against the wall exercising the cursed spirit
having seen this chosen was surprised by not only
yuji's power but his agility and control of
cursed energy describing him as a demon god
even though he still hasn't fully recovered from
the fights throughout shibuya dude like literally
is a demon god he has the immortal king inside
of him brother cho so you gotta realize that
one man he calls yuji impressive and addresses
him as his little brother once again which you
know i absolutely love yuji asks if he is going to
continue doing that and chozo answers that he will
adding that yuji's father had stitches on his
forehead which is obviously implying that yuji's
father would have been brain kun and like oh my
lord i don't even want to talk about the crazy
ass implications that this would throw into
the story like if it is true it's just mental
suddenly naoya appears above them and knows that
he doesn't see mega me as the two below notice
him naoya asks if they plan to run hearing this
though just leaves yuji slightly concerned as he
doesn't know why he would to which naomi reveals
that yuji's execution will now resume since
gojo is no longer around to protect him taking
all this in yuji then remembers aino's words about
how there are many sorcerers gojo has saved by
protecting them from the higher ups naouya tells
yuji that he doesn't care whether he lives or dies
since his business is with megami but states that
he can't allow him to be moving around freely so
instead he'll incapacitate him and wait for megami
yuji asks what he wants with his sorcerer to
which naoy replies that he plans for him to die
preferably after he writes something to help his
cause in that instant naoh leaps down and although
yuji notices his technique he's unable to avoid
a punch to his face which seems them sliding back
before yuji or chozo can move in to land ahead of
their own naru quickly jumps away and tells yuji
that he is stronger than expected and also wonders
to himself about the identity of the random man
with him now goes on to ask the two if he should
increase his speed but all three of them suddenly
stop when they feel an overwhelming presence yuji
initially thinks that it's gojo but then describes
it as something far darker and creepier he looks
up and sees the big man himself another of the
extremely freaking rare special grey sorcerers
yuta who calmly prepares his katana while
commenting on the fact that yuji is not alone as
yuta unsheathes his katana yuji asks who he is and
chozo seems to recognize his objective yuda jumps
down from the balcony and destroys a portion of
the wall on his way down leaving both choso and
yuji dumbfounded with his show of destruction
slowly approaching him he asks who the random is
to which chozo says to yuji that yuta must be his
executioner nao raises both his hands and assures
akotsu that he is on his side having heard the
name yuki recognizes him as the student mentioned
by megami and like gojo he's also a special great
sorcerer of unfathomable power naoyu introduces
himself as maki's cousin saying that his objective
is to kill yuji as well he assures yuta that he
won't interfere but goes to ask for something in
return while they do this chosen whispers to yuji
that he needs to run away since they still don't
know the trick to nail your speed she asks if he
will be okay holding him off and as he releases
blood manipulation chozu tells yuji that he has
to focus on getting away from utah pointing out
that if he tries to fight someone of that strength
he will be killed no matter what on the other side
now asks yuta to hold off on telling the higher
ups if he does kill yuji revealing that he is bait
for someone he intends to meet back with the
brothers chosen whispers to yuji that he will
meet him at yesterday's spot to which yuji agrees
then quickly after yudur agrees to naoya's plan
leaving chosu to him everyone suddenly makes
their move with yuta instantly sprinting past
chozo towards yuji chozo attempts to slow him
down with a passing bloodshot but naomi manages to
interrupt the attack yuji sprints away from yuta
each being caught by surprise at the other speed
as chozu wonders if they guessed his last move
he readies up his blood manipulation once again
but naoya quickly strikes him before he can use
it although he is unsure as to why chozo has the
blood manipulation ability naoyu remains unfazed
by it with the exception of passing blood he ends
his explanation since the rest is obvious to him
telling cho so that it's now time for him to die
however chosen's mood changes as he becomes
serious and he asks naoya if he thinks he will
leave alive after he just tried to murder his
little brother it's so funny like he's got like
a crew of these jacked up ass brothers following
him around making sure that he doesn't die at
the moment i absolutely love it anyways anyways
skipping away from the underpass yuji sprints
toward a car resting on its side and loops over it
with you to quickly run into the other side with
his katana ready however yuji grabs onto the car
and transposes his direction just barely dodging
the attack yuta is left stunned since he thought
he made contact telling yuji that he's just like
maki with his natural physical abilities yuji then
punches their car towards utah and since he knows
that he can't win out in the open tries to run
towards a set of buildings however the car is
suddenly thrown back above yuji's head stopping
him instantly you ask yuji if he is surprised
since he doesn't look like the strong type yuji
recognises though the enormous amount of cursed
energy pouring from him and realizes that they too
are polar opposites which is you know like hella
cool queen versus king type thing i'd love to see
like more hyped feats from like rika and yuta in
general and sukuna as well and yuji just so we
can pair them up in this massive battle to see who
would come out on top when they're going like full
tit against each other honestly like let me know
what you guys think down in the description below
i've always loved the idea of these two just going
freaking at it for like hours on end kind of like
a like a one-piece battle of like a kainu versus
aokiji where they fought for like seven days on
an island and changed the geography of their area
like i love that whole idea anyway anyway youtube
then reveals that while he has more cursed energy
than gojo the teacher's six eyes allow him to
reduce the curse energy when he activates a
technique to almost zero allowing him to fight
almost indefinitely after yuda says that he is
done gassing up big gojo he sprints towards
yuji who while overwhelmed remembers toto's
words about an elite sorceress flow of cursed
energy and it being difficult to read user then
strikes and seems to make contact with his side
of yuji's head but this student quickly recovers
and recognizes that yuda's body and katana are
constantly surging with energy he tells himself
that the issue isn't his moves but the fact that
he is decisive with every strike and can reduce
any damage you take to a minimum he remembers
nanami's final words to him and tells yuta that he
can't die yet however user keeps on the offensive
and although yuji dodges almost all of his strikes
one of them grazes his cheek and opens up a cart
he realizes that he needs to do something about
yuda's katana he tells himself that he doesn't
need to fear blades if he reinforces his body
with cursed energy but also can't overthink the
situation otherwise he'll end up dead as he dashes
towards a large suv he jumps inside the open
window and spots a knife on his seat he quickly
picks it up before jumping out the opposite window
and continuing on running user leaps over the hood
and attacks him with his katana though but yuji
uses the survival knife that he just picked up
to block the strike yuji is taken aback at first
and wonders where in the world did yuji get a
knife from but quickly realizes that it must
have been inside of the car yuji then lunges
forward to close the gap and abuse the knife of
cursed energy trying to fight back he remembers
gojo's words about not relying on curse tools to
the detriment of his own cursed energy's control
as the clash continues yuji knows that he hasn't
learned how to fight this way and then in a quick
flash yuda tells him that he is focusing too much
on his katana before raising it above his head and
kicking him in the stomach sending him reeling
back you she can't believe the power of his kick
but even still he quickly recovers user then
follows up with an even more powerful strike
that breaks yuji's knife and cuts into his stomach
however did you use the momentum of you to strike
to lodge his sword into the ground he then follows
up and pins it down and breaks the blade with his
thoughts which is like insane by the way i i know
this isn't a curse tool or anything but still it
had you just cursed energy flowing through it and
most likely protecting it in some kind of way even
yuda is surprised at first but calms himself down
while saying aloud that the fight was never going
to be easy although yuji's wound is deep he tells
himself that his vitals are intact and that both
of them are now unarmed but as he moves forward to
strike a large ominous creature suddenly appears
behind him and puts both of its hands around his
head she is frozen in fear and youtube tells rika
that they two were just playing yuji he was like
obviously confused and doesn't know what to make
of it or the name or what's going on wonders if
it's a shikagami as yuji struggles user tells
rika to hold the student still he then proceeds to
calmly stab him in the chest with a broken katana
as blood starts to drip from yuji's mouth
yuta looks him in the eyes and apologizes
inside of yuji sekuna is completely caught off
guard at first but soon notices something and puts
on his malevolent smile back in the underpass with
another of the parallels like just gonna add in
some more of my own brain cells right here but i
don't know why it's taking me this long to realize
both parties in this arc are like parallels or
like opposites of each other in the regards that
choso loves his siblings where naomi despises his
yuta has raker and yuji has secona like i find it
pretty interesting how giga always seems to have a
bunch of different themes going on throughout each
arc literally like all at the same time anyways
anyways chosu struggles to keep up with the speed
of naoya who uses his basic pitch version of
projection sorcery to dart around and hit cho
so with a hard punch to his guards reeling from
the attack chozu tells himself that he has no clue
what kind of curse technique naoh is using and
that he most likely won't reveal it since he
is winning so easily naoya continues to overwhelm
our boy with strikes while chose her comments that
convergence isn't a viable option since he can't
even control the blood outside of his own body
mr big bad zenning then compliments him on
his strength while asking exactly who he is
cho so in typical big profession confidently
says that he is the oldest of 10 siblings before
suddenly using the ord over flowing red scale
stack changing their markings on his face and
causing new ones to appear by the way the reason
this technique literally like shits all over
carmo's new one is because big choso has improved
on the basic version and pretty much made his
own kind of like what other characters do with
barriers and their own abilities throughout the
you know world after chozu says that he is
the oldest of the 10 siblings naoh clarifies
that he's asking about his curse technique and
toughness suddenly disappearing from chosen's view
cho so notices that blue beside him though and
quickly turns to face the incredibly fast naoya
who realizes that chozu has focused flowing red
scale and the muscle of his eyes to raise their
sharpness so that he can adjust to his speed
however naoya easily counters chozo's counter
striking him in the stomach and saying that he
always assumes someone will counter him first
as chosu recovers from his strike blood suddenly
begins to pour from an open wound in his chest
naomi reveals that he decided to use a
knife to affect his blood manipulation
asking him how long he can continue to fight in
that condition oh messed up here with just one
damn thing he disrespected his younger siblings
and doesn't even truly realize what cho so is
as well like i can't even believe that at
this point josue looks like a pale zombie
anyway anyway chosen commends his plan when
naomi continues talking about how using hidden
weapons isn't considered cool he adds that many do
carry them around and are often dependent on them
saying that the way in which his older
brothers show off their weapons is pathetic
and how he was always disgusted at the fact
they feared toji chozo mentions nao's dislike
for his brothers and now he says that the older
brothers who are weaker than the younger brothers
should just hang themselves and die since they
are pointless which is so freaking wild man like
this guy's mind is so damn broken at this point
he needs help man someone help him jose replies
that new may be the way he is now because
of his brothers and the way they treated him
twitch neo your scoffs at chosu's cliche reasoning
big bro choco continues by saying that regardless
of their strength older brothers are role models
and give the younger brothers the chance to avoid
the mistakes that they make themselves or to
follow behind them if they go down the right path
he asks naoya to consider the possibility that
he is strong only because his older brothers are
weak jose then reveals that he is strong because
he had no one older to guide him forcing him to
face his own mistakes and continue walking ahead
of his younger brothers as the blood from chozo's
wound pulls at his feet and begins to blow away
from him now your back's up and wonders how can
he survive after so much blood loss it's then
finally explained the death paintings have blood
mixed from cursed spirits and humans allowing them
to not die from blood loss since they can convert
cursed energy back into blood choker then raises a
wall of blood which causes nalia to lose sight of
him however a slower slicing exorcism attack comes
shooting out of the blood which now easily ducks
below and comes to the conclusion that chozo is
finally dying from the blood loss however chosen
suddenly appears several fake to the left of mr
misogyny and fires a passing blood shot which
he barely dodges but quickly understands that he
can't make contact with while the wall of blood
still flowing toward him naoya barely blocks
a kick from choso and finds that some of the
blood has actually stained his akama he wonders if
the blood now covering him is also affecting his
movement opposite him and standing tall trojan
prepares to fight another piercing bloodshot as
blood hovers around him almost mimicking the wing
king ability that esop had possessed he tells naoh
that he knows what comes next and that now it's
checkmate naoy remains confident and tells himself
that he can still move despite the binding effect
he tells choso to go ahead and fire but as he
dashes towards him he has a moment of hesitation
where he wonders why chozo isn't releasing the
attack as then explained in a typical cutaway
anime manga style that the move choco would use
was his own so you all know a [__] of ability
is about to go off created after he honed his
technique for a hundred and fifty years choso
then releases a supernova attack causing a large
orb of blood to shoot out in several directions
and strike all over the entirety of naoh's body
leaving him utterly finished chosu apologizes and
says they lost because he didn't love his brothers
however behind choso yuta suddenly appears
dragging an unconscious yugi by his hoodie josue
tries to react but yuta effortlessly strikes him
in the side of the face which in turn knocks him
straight to the ground as naoh looks up yuda says
and what feels like a damn degrading tone that he
seems to be hurt like oh you're okay down there
little nail your man you seem a little bit hurt
as user looks down on the wounded nayota the
letter glares back at him before vomiting up
blood he worries that chosen's blood manipulation
poisoned him but assures himself that it isn't the
effect of a curse technique he then realizes that
cho so must be a full-on curse because of how much
blood he used then guesses that his own body is
rejecting the non-human blood gouta still standing
above him offers to heal him with his reverse
curse technique if he tells his superiors that
yuji is dead well that is the end of the battle
that takes place and finally wraps up all of
the madness that has literally been going on for
over 60 freaking chapters but don't worry because
imma finish off this video with probably the most
freaking mind twisting and series changing moment
anyways a man named jyn is seen holding their baby
which is obviously the big man himself yuji and
his daddy-o oh hopefully anyway the man tells
his father that if he wants to talk about her
he will just leave the older man who's revealed
to be yuji's grandfather or suke itadori tells
jinn that while he can live his life however he
pleases he will die if he does not give up on her
jin tells wasuke to not say such things in front
of eugene since babies apparently remember more
than most believe and you know like we're seeing
that now which is an example of that and i hope
we get other flashbacks like this stuff revealed
to us from like youtube's parents because i want
to know so much more about this stuff here
super interesting to me unless none of it
out there was okay mentions the fact that jin
wanted a child with a normal woman named kaori
but before vasuke can continue on about her
death a woman with stitches on her forehead
interrupts him and addresses him as her
father-in-law asking what he's talking about
okay so the flashback ends there but well there's
insanity did she have the trial before branch took
over or was it after is brancon even in her head
or is it a tattoo i'm obviously assuming that it's
a brain cone in there and then it's taken over
during the pregnancy or before yuji got pregnant
she came back from the dead and then bonked with
daddy oh and now yuji's here and that's why he has
the blood relation with chozo and that's like
kind of my thoughts on that and real short but
let me know yours down below usually suddenly
awakens next to a fire as an emotionless uterus
sits nearby he's surprised that he's not dead and
user smiles with relief revealing that goku had
come to see him around september and asked if
he would watch over yuji skipping back to then
goku tells yuta to take care of the first
and second years if anything happens to him
well akari should be fine youtube wonders if gojo
means getting a girlfriend which is like randomly
funny since he can't imagine anything actually
happening to the big man himself goju specifies
that his primary concern should be the first year
named yuji itadori gojiri then asks where miguel
is but yuda replies that he doesn't want to see
gojo and this is probably to do with like miguel
and the special rope that he had during jjk zero
you know like in his fight that he had with gojo
back in the present yuda says that he put
on an act for the higher-ups so that he
would be the executioner in charge and know
all about the details of what's going on
he adds that to get approved as yuji's executioner
he had to enter a binding vow to actually kill him
a confused yuji asks how he's still alive then
to which yuda replies that the very instant his
heart stopped he healed him with his reversed
curse technique he adds that not many people
even know that he has the ability and guessed that
it would work on ug yuda points out that because
it's the second time that yuji's death has been
staged the higher ups will learn the truth soon
but will consider his death sentence complete
for the time being yuji wonders why he's doing
all of this for him and yuda replies that yuji
is important to people who are important to him
he tells yuji that he also used to possess a power
that he couldn't handle but says that while he
invited his own upon himself usually did not and
shouldn't be blamed for that which is you know
like super wholesome from him because he knows
where he's coming from yuji says that the blame
isn't the issue but before he can continue megami
finally shows himself and suddenly walks out of
the darkness while telling yuji that they should
head back to jiu jitsu high before megami can
finish mentioning rejoining the oldest students
yuji interrupts him by telling him not to act
like everything is normal and nothing happened
youtube remembers yuji's words about not being
able to die yet and says to himself that eugene
is unsure whether he deserves to live or not
realizing that it's the reason why he held back
when they two were fighting yuji then yells out
in pure desperation that he has killed people and
many others are dead because of him but megan me
rebuttals that it's all their fault telling
yugi not to be selfish or give up by himself
as yuji stays quiet and says to himself that he
knew megami would say that megami lets out his
sigh and says that they are jews who sorcerers not
heroes fighting for justice he explains that they
can never be judged what they do and just have to
keep proving to others that they deserve to exist
adding that they can't think about themselves with
all of the other people they have to save megami
reminds yuji that that was his original motive but
yuji closes his eyes and says that it's because as
long as megami is around him he will suffer megami
like the best freaking mate you could ever have
then tells yuchi to start by saving him and
begsuji for his strength revealing that braincon
has started a culling game for those with cursed
energy and his sister sakurami has awakened one
and is now trapped the culling game's eight known
rules are then explained by the way there are like
many more rules that have been added or updated
throughout the current culling game arc this is
just the core eight rules that are first revealed
to them the first rule is that players must
declare their participation at any given barrier
within 19 days after awakening a curse technique
so like people like sakumi this is why she's
in grave danger because she has to go into a
barrier and activate her like jester participate
in this coloring game she has no other choice
players who break the first rule could have their
curse technique removed and this honestly results
in death that's what happens when you run out of
cursed energy you die three non-players who enter
the barrier become players and are considered
to have declared their participation upon entry
four points are scored by killing other people
5. points are determined by the game master with
saucer is worth 5 points and non-sorcerers worth
1 point players may spend 100 points excluding
the value of their own life with the game master
to add one new rule seven the game master must
accept any new rule except those that have a
considerable and prolonged effect on the game
so literally like no one can be like yo cancel the
game or end the game it's you can't make that rule
and finally the last one that has been revealed
so far eight players have their curse technique
removed if their score stays the same for 19 days
so you know like there's a whole mixture of things
going on right now like sakumi is in mad danger
she either needs to kill people or they need
to implement some new rule that means they can
transfer points to people so she has more points
after 19 days and doesn't die pretty much anyway
anyway so that officially brings us to the very
end of the entire itadore extermination arc from
jiu jitsu kaizen obviously this arc was [__]
like insane with all of the stuff that happened
throughout it like it's literally mind-blowing
with yuji's mum finally being revealed to us and
the fact that his brain can somehow like when the
actual did that happen and how did it even happen
like who was [__] who is what i want actually
that's literally what i want to know at the
end of the day obviously i'm in the middle
of freaking nowhere again which i thought i do
because i am on holiday right now and you know
the video is out late which is as per usual but
surprisingly i'm actually at the monument of tom
cruise's death after uh the last samurai so i
thought i'd show you all like this uh historic
and prestigious place that we uh we decided to
build after like the historic movie that really
raised our country's gdp obviously if you guys
have enjoyed the video and want to see more stuff
just like this then make sure you leave a comment
down below and let me know what kind of stuff you
want to see in the future like other series you
want me to go over fights or anything like that
obviously if you are new around here as well then
make sure you hit that subscribe button but anyway
for now it's been your professional degenerate
diavolo and i'll see you all in a bit bye